one of the bits I really enjoyed was
talking about the debates because
normally you prep for a debate because
it's going to be to to and fro with
arguments but he was playing just a
different game
that's right here's what I say in the
book because I think it's really
important if you follow politics and
you're interested watch like a debate or
a presentation or a rally with the sound
off and so if you watch with the sound
off you didn't pay attention to what he
was saying because much of it was untrue
and and and really
Mazzilli he you know he was very
dominant very you know very big filling
the stage you know gesturing and facial
expressions if you didn't know what he
was saying you would think well you know
boy he's out there really giving it to
her so you you really have to understand
both what you're trying to say and
accomplish and how to match that now the
second debate was the one I really
highlight in the book yes because I mean
once he loomed over me yes it was all
designed to get into mind you know he
was this yes of course I did I mean I
think any woman would know that somebody
and I was debating in my head and I kind
of shared this with the readers look I
practiced not getting flustered not
getting thrown off being calm and
composed which I think a president
should be not impulsive and not trying
to dominate all every encounter but
maybe I should have turned around and
said you're not going to intimidate me
like you try to intimidate women back
off you creep you know maybe I should
have said
it's a it's a real lesson it's kind of a
you know it's a thought lesson for women
in public life for the private sector
when you find yourself in these
positions where a male co-worker a boss
client is you know really pushing you
trying to dominate you our usual
response is to just hold ourselves
together and not respond because if
you're too hot they accuse you of being
angry if you're kind of apologetic like
please don't do that to me you're
accused of being weak it's really hard
to get right in the sweet spot of being
strong and effective without creating
additional blowback she was so angry she
was shrill you know those are the words
meant to keep women in their place and
I'm not putting up with it anymore I'm
gonna do everything I can to speak
[Applause]
[Music]
you